hey guys my hair is extremely
unbelievably incredibly pink right now
me and Lucinda go guys we just got back
from Frenchie's beauty parlor because we
had a big hair dyeing party because last
week we had a charity livestream where I
and I alone said that I was going to dye
my hair pink at first if we reached a
certain goal and then jacksepticeye said
that he was going to dice hair green and
he already did that earlier today and
then the cyndago guys wanted to join me
as well so we had a bunch of bleach in
our hair we recorded a lot of moments we
had a lot of fun and we have a catalogue
here for you so watch on and enjoy it's
gonna be fun ah hi everybody I'm here
with lacy at Frenchy's beauty parlor
just a little shadow it's about time to
get my hair dyed pink well I want kind
of like a bright pink a very obviously
painting not neon and
nice handsome King so starting a little
circle thing is always good idea as you
wash it and think oh I knew hi Cara
please don't work no I did frosted tips
for hot tubs in trumpet section marching
band
yeah it looks good but this'll look good
so Matt how you feeling right about now
little nervous regretting your choices
yeah
regretting agreeing to beat my editor
yeah yeah we're reading joining cyndago
absolutely I repent that every day okay
cool just so we're clear
hi there you know I just said he
regretted joining cyndago yeah he should
yeah we've tried to kill him we tried to
burn him with try to hurt him and see
that's actually true every video he's
died or been maimed in the war will
leave so Brian on Wednesday I came in
thinking oh they're just gonna be like
Auburn inch now it's blue so blue
primary whew alright thank you I love
you back sorry everybody say hi to Erica
and Jeff what happened to be fans of
mine that we're just in this parlor at
the same time we were I'm sure they
won't be talking away yeah just by sheer
coincidence you're dyeing your hair blue
eyes yeah Oh purple all right you should
go perform Bryan purple purple exactly
I'm really saying hey no way
I'm so it's Colin oh yeah all the stop
sections good anything okay I'm now
applying for
lacy is that it Lacey Lacey is applying
the bleach and it doesn't burn yet but
she warned me in my tingle
so I'm gonna compare it to all the other
pain of experience I had second-degree
burns on my hands as close to that I was
cooking chicken wings and then I was
stupid and thermometer broken the oil I
needed to dump it but I wanted to cool
it down first so I put water in and they
have bubbled over on my hands I have an
engineering student okay I got the
bleach in she's putting gloves on I'm
assuming she's gonna kill me now so this
might be goodbye thank you everybody so
much for watching I love you much
goodbye
okay the bleach is pretty much all the
way in now we're gonna let it set right
we're gonna let it set and burn me away
to ashes it's gonna be a pile of dust in
this chair yeah so Jack I hope this was
worth it sorry gone status update we
both have bleach in our hair Matt's
having the worst of it because it hurts
really bad really really bad Wow I'm not
doing so bad except for doing this again
my head is on fire
really yeah oh you need anything it's
physically hot just imagine how good
you're gonna look afterwards oh thanks I
look so good I didn't that's a lot it
burns a lot I'm actually doing a lot
yeah it hurts it didn't hurt to look out
on top oh it's not the toy people no
it's not painful it's just
well Daniel is a big baby he can't take
it he's gonna quit run out screaming
outside the door actually from behind it
was really weird cuz you look totally
bald from behind bizarre yeah yeah
that's cool I like that oh sorry I'm in
the way of everybody's like I stuck my
head in the thing of fire ants and
they're crawling around my head sting oh
man I don't even know how much time you
have I don't know either it hurts a
little bit oh all right so I have to
stand like this because of light so I'm
not weird but the bleach is almost done
we're going to get that out of on V
blonde for a little bit it actually
doesn't look too terribly bad and then
we got the pink really bright right yeah
really
super bright pink
okay so if it bleaches out and now I'm
looking pretty good one surprisingly I
actually really liked it but it has to
go to pink so will be coming next I feel
good about this choice that I made with
my life but the pinky is going in this
is the brightest pink they could
possibly make it because I wanted to
really pop and then it will fade over
time right yep hot hot pink uh-huh
Thanks come on look good I already look
good I mean I was so good but I really
look good I got like the whole crews
here we're almost ready
oh no you said record all in this yeah
you're like I put all this but I'm gonna
wait was it looks like it looks like
pigs
so it's finally done my scalp is a
little stained but this is pink this as
pink as pink could be yay
almost there just a little more almost
okay finally done she pulled me out into
the Sun just to show how much I glowed
so it's literally the brightest pink
I've ever seen so it's really cool
love it thank you very much all right
we're all done I think it's great
everybody I dig it I dig it Ryan has
them like wonderful rainbow fish I don't
know if I can touch with them
there we go Ryan's here I'm sure you
could touch yeah color dimmers yeah yeah
I hear ya so just blond boys to help ah
we're just couple boys got yeah I love
this pink is so they're so awesome yeah
I'm really happy without this turned out
so yay we did for charity hey guys join
me so thank you guys so much and check
out their video they got another behind
the scenes video on their channel yes
I'm much less happy there
yeah you'll see okay why